feel Elvis was controlling I've been
answering your question you answer mine
it's actually not my job to answer your
questions I've asked you two questions
should a mass stay in power and are they
a terror group you're refusing to answer
either of them that is very telling talk
TV is the only place that where you get
the truth you've done a book on poetry
poetry and music for the many I love
poetry we can agree on
that
on TV on Radio and on your smartphone
this is talk
[Music]
TV tonight appears Morgan uncensored the
King has cancer we'll bring you all the
latest breaking news and Analysis on a
night of shock and Sympathy for the
British royal
family live from the news building in
London this is Piers Morgan uncensored
good evening from London welcome to
Piers Morgan uncensored King Charles III
has been diagnosed with cancer the king
told close family members including his
sons Prince William and Prince Harry and
his three siblings the announcement was
made to the British public at 6 PM this
evening and shocked the world Prince
Harry the Duke of susex has told friends
he's flying into the UK over the next
few days to see his father who he's
already spoken to over the phone the
type of cancer has not been revealed
field but we do know from the palace it
is not prostate cancer but the cancer
was discovered during the king's recent
treatment for an enlar prostate well
Bucky and Palace said tonight the king
began regular treatments as an
outpatient on Monday he was last seen
publicly as recently as Sunday attending
church in Norfolk with his wife Queen
Camila he remains the head of state he
will undertake basic state duties from
the palace including his weekly meeting
with the Prime Minister but public
engagements have all been postponed for
the duration of his treatment it's
unclear if he'll be able to undertake
major International trips to Canada and
New Zealand planned over the coming
months well reaction as you'd expect is
pouring in from around the world here
prime minister Rishi sunak and sakir
starma have wished him a speedy recovery
in United States Donald Trump just
posted he's a wonderful man who I got to
know well during my presidency and we
all pray that he has a fast and full
recovery President Joe Biden said he's
concerned and hopes to talk to him soon
you have a message foring mingles call
concerned about him just heard his
diagnosis but I'll be talking god well
joining me now is talk TV's Royal editor
Sarah Houston Roy biographer Tom bow Fox
News contributor Mark seagull and former
editor of the Sunday Times Andrew Neil
okay well Sarah let's start with you
just on this breaking news I got told
just after 5:00 there's a massive
statement coming from Buckingham Palace
about King Charles and we think it's
canc
uh and I read the statement maybe just a
few minutes before it went out it was
shocking I mean you don't read this kind
of thing about a senior member of the RO
family and yet it comes just after the
previous Health statements about both
Charles having his his prostate
operation which was for a benign
situation and for Kate the Princess of
Wales a lot of Health stories about the
rules this is it appears to be by far
the most serious yes and you're right it
it has come as a shock because we know
the king went into Hospital for uh
planned procedure on uh an enlarged
prostate a benign uh enlarged prostate
we were told we thought that that was
very typical for a man of his age and we
were told that he'd put that diagnosis
out there because he wanted to raise
awareness he did have to stay in the
hospital a little bit longer than we had
initially thought he was in for three
nights he had regular visits from Queen
Camila during that period and it was
during that procedure that an area of
concern was noticed some I wonder about
the timing because I'm by people close
to to the Royals that as as as late as
like two days ago yesterday everything
seemed fine and it seems to me what
maybe more likely and maybe Dr Mar Eagle
can tell us this is that they took some
of his prostate away for further
examination in that operation he had and
then something nasty turned up which was
nothing to do with a prostate but it
revealed another cancer in his body and
I think that this has come as a shock to
everybody from what I can tell even
senior member of the royal family had no
idea this was coming absolutely and we
saw the king and the Queen at
Sandringham yesterday uh we do
understand that they knew last week uh
Queen Camila opened a Maggie's Cancer
Care Center we told that she did that
knowing the diagnosis we think that she
knew by that point we my understanding
is that she carried on with that
engagement and it will have taken on an
added significance of course uh for her
we know that the king told his siblings
uh an Edward and and Drew we don't know
but before this was made public and SP
to both sons okay so Tom I think this
has all happened pretty quickly and that
says to me this has come as a big shock
uh and that the royal family already
reeling from the deaths of Prince
Phillip from her majesty the queen from
the double Health blow that we heard
several weeks ago of Charles and Kate
and now this that our new monarch has
cancer well it does come as a sh but on
the other hand I must tell you that
before Christmas someone a neighbor of
his in hro did tell me that the king
wasn't well and also warn that Queen
Camila is not perfect health either so I
think that although it seems like it's a
great shock tonight to us I think this
has been coming for some time well just
bringing Andrew Neil uh Andrew you were
one of the great newspaper editors this
is one of those stories isn't it where
it breaks at 6:00 at night and everyone
is scrambling I'd imagine the papers
will be absolutely full of this tomorrow
what do what do you make of this and in
particular the wording of the palace
statement which I I got to say with my
own former newspaper editor haton I
think this looks quite a serious
situation well they told us more than
they usually do in these circumstances
they haven't told us anything like the
full picture we don't know what kind of
cancer it is but they told us more than
they usually do they told us more than
they did when the queen was getting
seriously unwell it is a huge story I've
been watching the American Network it's
the lead story in every American News
Network tonight I've been watching
French and German TV is the lead story
there as well it's the lead story in
every major Network I would guess around
the world and there will be a Temptation
for journalists to make Harry the story
because he's now going to be flying back
and we hope that uh at times of Crisis
or this is a crisis for the royal family
it can bring families together but I
hope we don't make Harry the story the
story is the king and the story is the
queen and Prince William uh and his wife
Kate who will have to step up to the
plate particularly when Kate gets better
to fill in uh some of the gaps that
Charles will leave behind the important
matter is the continuity of the British
state in these circumstances and the
core of the British state has a thousand
years of experience in dealing with
these things not many countries that can
say they've got a thousand years of
experience and I'm encouraged by the
fact that the king will still carry out
a lot of functions in private including
the privy Council and meeting the Prime
Minister and his red boxes but it's not
been thought necessary to create a
council of state that would take over
the functions the Constitutional
functions of the Monarch and I think
when you add all that together that's
encouraging the continuity will continue
and it's very important to us in an
election year yes because the purpose of
the monarchy is to provide continuity
and stability
regardless of what's happening in
politics and we're having an election
this year and it's very important that
the monarchy plays that role above
politics for the country as a whole yeah
very very good point Andrew we've got
Roy ncka who's the Royal correspondent
for the Sunday Times Andrew's old paper
before I come to you Roy I want to read
the Bucking and Palace statement in full
and then get your reaction to this it
says during the king's recent Hospital
procedure for benign prostate
enlargement a separate issue of concern
was noted subsequent diagnostic tests
have identified a form of cancer his
majesty has today commenced to schedule
regular treatments during which time
he's been advised by doctors to postpone
public facing duties throughout this
period his majesty will continue to
undertake State business and official
paperwork as usual the king is grateful
to his medical team for their Swift
Intervention which was made possible
thanks to his recent Hospital procedure
he remains wholly pos positive about his
treatment and looks forward to returning
to full public duty as soon as possible
possible his majesty has chosen to share
his diagnosis to prevent speculation and
in the hope it may assist public
understanding for all those around the
world affected by cancer so royya I mean
that was a bombshell statement and as
always with royal statements you kind of
look for the the devil in the detail if
you like and I got to say I like I said
I think this is quite a serious
situation which has emerged from a not
so serious situation which was the
procedure for the benign prostrate
enlargement this is clear
a separate and and is a cancer so it's
two it's a different thing Al together
and it's more
serious you can't PE um detract from the
fact that cancer is a very serious
diagnosis whatever form it is and we
don't know what form it is yet um we're
told you know he may choose to share
more uh information down the line during
his treatment but just to your point
about you know always unpicking
statements from the palace I have to say
I actually looked at that statement and
some of the guidance that we've had
tonight some background guidance we've
had for from um The Palace particularly
the items about no councilors of State
being needed so we are not going to see
Prince William or Prince Edward or an
stepping in constitutionally for the
king it's been made very clear quite
sort of firmly that constitutionally at
the moment nothing has changed the king
is going to keep doing his Affairs of
State his red boxes we just won't see
him in public so much so yes it's very
serious he's got cancer but at the same
time that phrase you know he is wholly
positive about his treat M and that he
is still doing Affairs of State I read
that as actually quite a hopeful sign
yeah but for a new king of less than a
year to no longer be doing any
engagements in front of the public I I
just think you know knowing Charles uh
as I have for a long time not not
particularly closely but having followed
his his life this is a tough guy a very
thick guy used to yumping around the
highlands and leading a very fit active
life for him to basic Retreat from
public life in the way that he is yes he
may be saying he's holy positive I
wouldn't expect anything else but I I I
think this must be a serious situation
because he he's counseling all public
engagements apparently while he
undergoes his
treatment I mean there's no doubt that
you know cancer is serious for anyone
but I think in terms of sort of
retreating from public view when you
know depending on what his treatment
involves the palace and the royal family
and the King himself will want to
minimize you know the health risk to him
in terms of it it's one thing to meet
with the Prime Minister and have an
audience with him as we're told
hopefully he will continue to do that
and meet with the privy Council it's
it's another thing to you know be at a
buck and Palace reception with 300
people in the room which I think is why
you know ering on the side of caution
for the head of state for our Monarch
he's with withdrawn but of course you
know you cannot sh away from the fact
that the king as you said just year and
a half into his Reign is having to
withdraw from public life temporarily we
hope is a huge blow to him huge blow to
his room it's going to be a big
challenge for him and the family to
Rally around yeah uh Tom the subplot
here um and Andrew NE was quite right
there shouldn't be the story but it's
interesting that there's obviously this
massive ongoing Rift with Prince Harry
and his father but we've been told from
Friends of Prince Harry that he's
planning to fly from California to see
his father which will be the nearest
thing to a reproach more we've seen you
do see this with families when they're
Waring is a dramatic event like this uh
can bring people together what do you
make of that well I think that uh RMA is
fitting on the other hand I'm very
suspicious uh because as we've discussed
often here um Harry's agenda has been so
anti-monarchist has been so
disrespectful of the king and the Queen
and of course of his brother that for
him suddenly to turn up in London not
having expressed any uh concern for his
father when he heard originally about
the prostrate problem which is two weeks
ago uh that's been a per of Silence so
suddenly he's flying in I think it
seemen two things not the r only but
also how serious it is I don't think it
is a benign issue at all I think you're
quite right that there is a there is a
mini crisis happening yeah and Andrew
Neil if like could come back to you uh
for a moment you know we've covered the
Royals for many many decades and they've
always been the biggest story in town
and like you say the news of the king's
diagnosis is leading the news around the
world not least in America um where it's
huge I've had of calls and people
wanting interviews about this already so
you can see you can see how big a story
this is but does it also point to the
fragility of our royal family right now
we've lost the great matriarch in the
queen we lost the great patriarch in
Prince Phillip we've now got the
Princess of Wales who's having months
off uh work because of uh we don't know
what what it was that she had but it was
obviously pretty serious uh we've got
Charles now the new monarch who has
cancer you know if you look at the sort
of top the top list of Royals this is a
this is a big moment isn't it I mean
this is a like I say this this points to
the fragility of the whole
thing it's coming a bad time because
cancer diagnos has never come at a good
time but it with the royal family we've
gone from Surplus to famine uh very very
quickly I mean a lot of people say I
don't mind uh the king or the queen I
don't mind the very top rows but I don't
like all these hang on well a lot of the
so my mother used to call them Hangers
On well these kind of Royals seem to
have stopped hanging on they've
disappeared now prince Andrew is no
longer in in the game Prince Harry
candied himself out along with Megan the
Princess of Wales has not been well so
William has refused himself uh too we
are now have a royal family that's is
pretty short-handed and of course this
will put huge strain on the queen at a
very difficult time for her but also
more strain on William who was hoping to
step back and look after his wife he is
now under pressure and will succumb to
that pressure to get back into public
life and pick up some of these public
engagements so it's um the productivity
of the remaining senior members of the
royal family who able to do what royal
should be doing not many of them anymore
that will have to increase in the weeks
and months ahead and I think the other
thing to look for this is just a
breaking story p as you know we do not
know what kind of cancer it is the whole
cancer is scary and bad we do not know
the treatment that the caning is getting
or what impact the treatment will have
on the king himself which I think is
very important so I think in the days
and probably the weeks ahead we'll get a
better idea of whether the K whether the
king will be able to carry on in private
with his important duties and eventually
come back to public life or whether it's
so serious that even in private his
duties are now hard to to C car out that
to my mind is the thing to look for in
the weeks ahead yeah I completely agree
Sarah I mean Andrew is so right isn't it
that the number of top people in the
royal family available to do the
functional work of the royal family
which is huge I mean they all do
hundreds of Royal engagements a year
these can be big ones small ones but
they're serving the people that's the
deal the contract with the British
public there aren't many of them at the
moment able to actually work no and and
and those that are working already have
packed schedules an for example has an
incredibly busy Di and and the king is
going to be relying on his sister now
also on uh Sophie The Duchess of
Edinburgh Ron Edward the the Duke of
Edinburgh uh and Prince William but as
Andrew was saying Prince William was
hoping to take some time out to be
looking after his wife and children next
week is halterm the children will be
home from school Kate not really able uh
to be carrying on as normal but we had
the announcement today and I think the
timing of that was significant and
choreographed that he's back to public
duties on Wednesday he's going to be
hosting an investure at Windsor Castle
he's got an event on Wednesday he needs
to be seen because as the late Queen
used to say you know they're all family
need to be seen remembering William will
be very worried about his wife and
worried about his father and Camila will
be absolutely you know heartbroken about
what's going on with Charles the great
love of her life never Mount the public
duty stuff she's going to carry on with
her duties they presumably some of them
will have to pick up some of the Kings
at some stage of his carries on but
she'll also have in her own world this
is a devastating moment and it's
sometimes it's easy to forget human
being supporting him through his
treatment as well because we don't know
what impact it's going to have on him
you talked about reading line between
the lines of the statements uh now we
look back on some of the words that
Camila has said over the past couple of
weeks initially when she was asked she
said he was doing fine last week she
said he's doing his best yes uh when she
was asked how he was and that takes on a
greater significance now we know what
has been going on okay Andrew Neil and
Roy nck thank you both very much indeed
I think you guys are staying with me uh
uncensored next we're getting more on
the breaking news that King Charles has
been diagnosed with a form of cancer
we'll talk to a constitutional expert
what does this all mean actually for the
monarchy if God forbid this turns into a
very serious situation involving our
[Music]
Monarch we're here thanks for joining us
you're with talk TV on TV on radio
online and we're on your smart speaking
criminals to using XL Bully dogs as
weapons to threaten others no matter how
well trained most dog owners will tell
you a dog can turn you know what I love
about to today we do it all sunak sella
scon a woman can become a man and a man
can become a woman and if you think that
you're certifiably
insane slick Wishy seemed intelligent
forensic even a bit of a Statesman the
type of man you trust to look after your
house while you went on
holiday this concept that actually kids
wouldn't carry knives if they could go
and play Tiddly Winks at the you know
the corner of the street or whatever I
think it's a
nonsense happy th night we slick it
timorous Beast open panics
in G stas accused the government of
failing a generation after a record
number of young people were killed last
year using a knel sharp object we need
to make sure that when we say we're
going to ban them we actually do ban
them there so many politicians now who
just said my dad was a
Bost you're David Cameron no he
wasn't was like brought to you by
sadique Khan the mayor of London very
rarely meet anybody that says you know
the thing about London is it's got a
great mayor Sadi Khan brilliant
guy in the cities there are areas where
there are no vegetables it's
particularly difficult for those people
to do what Mark is saying if he comes up
with this argument again I'll sit on
him stop cre creating all of these funny
little factions with their funny little
names the new conservatives the ERG the
common sense research group the red wool
red Prower popcorn I mean popcorn what
what is that if you're talking about
multiculturalism it's workingclass white
boys who get put in the Army the poorest
people in society are the ones who are
going to be put on the front line
something is going horribly wrong we can
do a lot better Donald Trump didn't just
win he obliterated this is a guy facing
nearly a hundred criminal charges and
yet all that's done is actually make him
more popular Trump is canny enough to
know that all publicity is good
publicity I don't want a president who's
been impeached if he's able to bamboozle
you that's the way it goes did my six
months I came back nobody would touch me
I put my head down and persisted and
carried on when I say I am God I'm not
joking did you feel Elvis was
controlling I've been answering your
question you answer mine it's actually
not my job to answer your questions I've
ask you two questions should a mass stay
in power and are they a terror group
you're refusing to answer either of them
that is very telling talk TV is the only
place where you get the truth you've
done a book on poetry poetry and music
for the many I love poetry we can agree
on
[Music]
that
welcome back to unsensed well Sarah
Houston and Tom B are still with me
along with historian and author S
Anthony Seldon s Anthony a big shock
tonight for the country for the world
that King Charles III has been diagnosed
with cancer we don't know what the
cancer is we don't know how serious it
is but we do know he's canceling all
engagements where he would have to face
the public for the foreseeable future
what do you read into
this I don't know what to read in it to
appears I mean it's um it's so
unexpected we can uh read so many
different things into it it could be uh
just uh precaution he is 75 he's not a
young man it could be the doctors are
just saying let's take it very uh
steadily and cautiously and carefully
but there's nothing um very much to to
worry about that we can't deal with with
our modern treatments at one end of the
spectrum or the other it could be a
serious and advanced form of cancer at
the moment I don't know I don't know if
uh anybody else does outside the roal
circle what San what are the
Constitutional implications of this
situation if we assume for a moment God
forbid that the king is very seriously
ill with a serious cancer and that there
is a possibility that he may not come
through it that's the worst case
scenario obviously and we don't know for
a moment that that is the case but what
is the Constitution situation
here so uh it does show that the
monarchy really matters in in modern
Britain I mean why are we talking about
it why is the world obsessed about this
um uh today uh when there are so many
other pressing issues Wars and in this
country uh uh the prospects of general
election and Party politics it's all
been swept aside and why uh and in a way
it's very hard to say exactly what uh
the monarchy does do but we do know that
it's important not important because
many people majority of the country like
it and want it to continue but because
it's filling fulfilling part of our
constitutional function um it does help
hold the United Kingdom together take
away the monarchy and there's not a
great deal holding together the
constituent nations of the uh United
Kingdom it does help provide a sense of
continu
meaning and and purpose and somebody has
to do it so what will happen has already
been pointed out um with uh princess
Katherine herself unwell and we don't
quite know uh what's going on with her
that's a lot falling back on on William
but also on his two functioning siblings
of Edward uh and Princess an um but
they're not um they're not exactly front
tier figure is uh so uh there will be
cover I mean what's important what we
know is that this monarchy fights it
hasn't survived uh for 950 years uh
without fighting for its survival and it
will make do uh somehow uh the whatever
absence um or whatever problem this is
but frany on the Constitution if the
king is
incapacitated what happens then if he's
alive but incapacitated if you can't
perform the functions of state if you
can't see the Prime Minister and so on
what happens in that
eventuality well eventually there could
be a Regency as happened with George III
who was incapacitated through mental
problems he reigned for 60 years but um
by the beginning of the 19th century he
clearly was incapable of providing that
steadiness of purpose in a at a time
that the monarchy was more Central and
important in the country than it is now
so uh there would be some form of
Regency and I would imagine uh that
William would step up and become the uh
the Regent uh and that he would be
taking over the political functions uh
of uh the monarchy so that those U
essential functions for the continuity
of the British State uh would be allowed
seamlessly to continue Ry Thank you very
very much indeed I'm joined now from
United States by Dr Mark seagull he's
the Fox News contributor uh Dr Mark
great to see you um big bombshell news
tonight I know it's making big news
across the pond in America um when you
read the statement from the palace and
it says it it when he had the procedure
for the benign prostate enlargement a
separate issue of concern was noted
which is another form of cancer has been
identified um just talk me through the
proc C that could have led to that
Discovery Well Pi good good to see you
and we actually talked together about
this at the very beginning when he went
in for the procedure now I talked to our
top urologist at NYU New York University
today about this issue with the prostate
and he said about one out of a hundred
times when you're there when you're
going in you could see a bladder cancer
that it could look like a large prostate
or it could be there at the same time as
en llarge prostate or it could come out
on
pathology one out of a 100 times or more
that happens I'll tell you Piers I'm
suspicious that this is bladder cancer
because he went home because they're
treating him as an outpatient because
what you do with bladder cancer after
you resect it if you can resect
it you give BCG which is a form of
inactivated bacteria like tuberculosis
you infuse that into the bladder and it
cures it over 90% of the time it's the
fourth most common cancer in men number
two number one is prostate cancer which
they say this is not lung cancer colon
cancer they those could have spread but
the king of England I think would be
getting impatient treatment for those so
I'm suspicious that this is bladder
cancer and that would be good news well
that's encouraging if that's what it is
we've been asked not to speculate about
what it is but it's impossible really
given that we know the King has cancer
not to at least theorize what the range
of cancers it could be given that it was
discovered from this procedure for the
benign prostate enlargement I mean so I
heard a doctor this morning uh this
evening on the radio talking about how
when you have that benign prostate
enlargement if you are the king they
probably took some tissue from the
prostate area as well and that it may
have taken some time for that to be
properly tested and come back would that
be consistent with a bladder cancer
discovery and could it also have
Unearthed something else completely
different in other words like you say
could it have been a secondary site uh
for a lung cancer or colon cancer or
something of that
nature absolutely all of those things
are possible I'm just Cons considering
the idea that he went home and and as
you say they ask us not to speculate but
if I'm right this is very very very good
news this also happens pretty commonly
and also they didn't talk about CAT scan
or other
tests you know this is this is most
likely something you would find while
you're doing the other
procedure so you would be quietly
encouraged by the sequence of
events because he went home because the
king of England went home and because if
they found this now another possibility
might be lymphoma lymphoma is eminently
treatable as well but again I would have
expected the king to be treated in the
hospital for that at least initially so
the fact that I'm encouraged by the fact
that he went home and that he's getting
the treatment as an outpatient I find
very encouraging that seems to me to be
a significant part of this I mean we we
know that was the case on Monday what we
don't know from that statement is
whether he will remain an outpatient or
whether he will actually have to go in
as well all we do know is that all
public engagements involving FaceTime
with the public have all been cancelled
or postponed uh that is very very
unusual Dr to Mar which suggests to me
that whatever it is they're very worried
about
it well or that he has a recovery time
here or that he had surgery done you
know if it was if it was bladder cancer
they would have tried to remove it at
the time that they were doing the
prostate if it's metastatic cancer of
another
sort it still can respond to
chemotherapy or immunotherapy or
radiation but it would be more dire in
that than if it were the bladder what I
mean if it is the bladder cancer and as
you say if he's had the procedure that
you said he may have had for that what's
the recovery time period
like well that would be a a matter of
weeks of course he's 75 years old that
factors into it he's in pretty pretty
fit and as you know Pierce he's the
anti-smoking King he's been he's been
asking for no smoking in all of the UK
so that's good because because more
likely these cancers are related to
smoking so so he's a healthy King and
and I I think that that bodess well for
a faster recovery unless he has a more
severe cancer right uh Dr Mark as always
great to talk to you thank you so much
for sparing the time I know you're very
very busy over there with all the stuff
going at Fox so I appreciate it thank
you very
much well we're going to take another
break we're going to come back and talk
to Tessa Dunlop who's a royal historian
uh and also Dicky AER the former press
secretary to the queen on this big new
blow so stay with us but more on the big
breaking
story we're here thanks for joining us
you're with talk TV on TV on radio
online on your smart speaker as well you
know what I love about talk today we do
it all sunak sella
scon I rather like David Cameron I don't
sort of bear him any ill will because he
delivered the referendum that he said he
would deliver the tor's love a scrap you
can almost see this coming around the
tracks with sella bravman she's heading
up one side and richy soon at the other
the police are pro Palestine that is
just not right you swear an o in the
police to act without fear or favor the
co inquiry seems to have turned into a
sort of pantomim there's not really any
substance to it it's hard to know
whether it's a fce or a tragedy there
needs to be one human per machine to
come and rectify beats and the clanks
and when it goes R unexpected item in
bagging area
are we only going to be trusting sources
like meta and Google where is our
unbiased news going to come from at Gram
was president of the Cambridge Union
which is the rubbish version of being
president of the Oxford
Union Kevin O Sullivan is the worst
presenter on talk TV sitting on his fat
ass talking living if you're walking
towards me and you're a vegan you have a
great big orange sticker over here
saying watch out vegans about Twitter
you sons of can you please reinstate my
account thank you this is a major Summit
President Biden decided this was
important after watching a Tom Cruz
film kids think all they have to do is
take pictures of everything just shut
down Tik Tok problem solved when I say I
am God I'm not joking did you feel Elvis
was controlling I've been answering your
question you answer mine it's actually
not my job to answer your question are
you prepared to call h a terror group is
it possible to have a
rational talk TV it's the only place
where you get the
truth this is talk
[Music]
TV welcome back to a special edition of
PE more un sensed about the bombshell
news that King Charles III has been
diagnosed with cancer still with me is
Tom B along with ro historian now Tessa
Dunlop and the former press secretary to
the late Queen dicki ariton before I
come to uh our new guests just some more
tributes pouring in from everywhere all
around the world the Israel prime
minister Benjamin Netanyahu Sarah and I
send our heartfelt well well wishes to
King Charles III our prayers for his
good health um Joe Biden we quoted
earlier yes I'm concerned about him I've
just heard his diagnosis hopefully I'll
be talking to him soon Justin Trudeau
the prime minister of Canada I like I
like Canadians across the country and
people around the world I'm thinking of
his majesty King Charles II as he
undergo treatment for cancer London
mayor Sadi Khan wish the king a speedy
and full recovery of behalf of londoners
I look forward to his return to full
health as soon as possible and the
former prime minister Boris Johnson the
whole country will be rooting for the
King today best wishes to Charles III
for a full and speedy recovery and
they're coming in from literally every
quarter of the world as this news
reverberates around the globe well let
me go to Dicky Arbiter Dicky you've
dealt with many Royal crises in your
time hard to imagine many more serious
than our new monarch of just a year and
a half uh taking over from the late
great queen and the enormity of her own
death that he's now been diagnosed with
cancer what's your reaction to this well
my initial reaction to it is that good
on Buckingham Palace for announcing that
the king does have cancer because if
he's not seen out and about which is his
job uh there'll be a lot of speculation
as to where he is it made very clear
that uh he is robust he will continue
with his constitutional role and that's
going through red boxes of papers of
State uh which he has to do and also
audiences with the prime minister so
that will carry on the only difference
is that we won't see him out and about
the part that he really enjoys is going
up and down the country whether it's
England Ireland Scotland Wales whatever
or or abroad he will miss that he will
miss meeting the people he will miss
meeting businessmen industrialists
politicians but he's got to live with
that and he has been told that he does
have cancer he will have treatment what
is interesting and Dr seagull did make
the point that he's being treated at
home and that is that is probably good
news that they didn't feel that it
necessary the medic studies to treat him
in hospitals so treating at home is good
news it means he can carry on with a
fairly normal life orbe it restricted in
not going out and about and I think it's
good that Buckingham Palace did announce
it they wouldn't have done it without
his say so and he just show a new
monarchy a new attitude towards uh the
ills of of of mankind that they have
announc that he has cancer and we can
just hope that in the fullness of time
he will be he will be cured got to
remember that we are already in February
engagements usually go up until the end
of March when Easter court is in play
and very rarely any engagements and I
don't think we'll see the king back
until after see after Easter and very
much the princess of Wales we won't see
her back until after Easter but I think
along with everybody else globally that
we wish the king well yeah absolutely uh
Tessa Dunlop a big
shock yeah and one can't help but feel
great Sympathy For King Charles he's
been in a job that he's waited his
entire life for for one year and four
months and this news um will have come
as a shock the word cancer always comes
as a shock he's shared but he's not over
shared we don't know of course what the
treatment will be and we don't know what
cancer he has but I think we can feel
cautiously optimistic rishy mentioned he
would be having still his weekly
meetings with the Monarch Tom ba it was
interesting there was a big media
briefing attached to the statement which
was not for publication very detailed
very long actually five pages or so and
as I was reading I was thinking this is
not something you would do if this was a
trivial matter I I do think we're
watching live pictures outside buck and
Palace I do think there's a lot of
concern there I think there's a lot of
concern and rightly so I mean uh King
Charles is after our Monarch he's an old
man 75 uh I think it has come as a shock
to the public I don't think that it was
a complete shock to him I think he
already was feeling unwell for some
weeks and I think that we're just not
ready after having after all we lost the
queen we don't really want to lose the
king no and I think that is the problem
that as as Dr s s rightly said we rely
on the monarchy to keep this country
together we rely on the monarchy to
represent us of all these amazing uh
Charities and all the rest that they the
work they do and without them I think
the country is lost and I think that's
what we've got to fear that somehow as
you rightly say there's a depletion in
the ranks yes uh Dicky Arbiter I mean
just on uh forthcoming events that would
have involved the king being Senter
stage Commonwealth day service at
Westminster Abby on March the 11th uh
and then the king and queen were
expected to visit Canada in May and then
Australia New Zealand and Samoa for the
Commonwealth heads of government meeting
in October I mean these are all big
events um particular the foreign tours
and visits um we don't know of course
whether he'll be up to doing this but
what would happen if he's not able to go
do they simply postpone it do they send
queen killer on her own do they send
other members of the family what would
you be do thinking if you were at the
palace now well let me rewind slightly
and if it was the uh Commonwealth heads
of government meeting you can't postpone
that I mean it has been postponed in the
past because of covid but there is no
reason for it to be postponed and the
King could quite easily delegate uh the
Prince of Wales to go in much the same
way as the late Queen delegated uh the
king current King when he was Prince of
Wales to go in herstead so that is not
impossible as far as state visits are
turn to Canada and Australia these could
still go ahead in terms of the Prince of
Wales going and let's hope that the
Princess of Wales uh becomes uh fit and
healthy and well to be able to resume
duties so uh it's not lost it's not lost
at all but you know you're talking about
events in May in October and these are a
long time hence uh we're only at the
beginning of February and I think with
the right treatment the right care uh
and the right uh peace of mind uh on
behalf of the king that we will see him
back in harness after Easter but as far
as those engagements are concerned
they're not lost they won't be postponed
Tess the statement said the man has
chosen to share the diagnosis very
unusual to do this to prevent
speculation and in the hope it may
assist public understanding for those
around the world affected by cancer I
thought that was quite a significant
change as Dicky suggested earlier to
normal procedure when it comes to
matters of Health involving senior
Royals very true the late Queen I think
the most we got from her was poor
mobility issues even when she was in the
depths of her 90s her own father looked
literally like walking death towards the
end of his life doctors could guess that
he had cancer but no word was uttered in
fact in his Christmas speech just sort
of six weeks prior to his death he
talked about uh the NHS and the doctors
and nurses is making him well again so
this is a sea change of course we live
in very different times the King has
gone to Great Lengths to try and
establish himself as a more empathetic
Progressive Monarch and this is in
keeping with that and like I say he
shared but he's not overshare we don't
know what the cancer is we don't know
what the treatment would be regarding
those trips um the Edinburgh as they
were then Philip and Elizabeth of course
stepped in for her father and they went
to Canada and America in 19 1951 and
depending on Kate's health and of course
how their children are because they have
pretty heavy familial duties with three
of their own we might see Kate and
Williams step into the breach for that
Australian New Zealand tour which by
definition being Long Haul will be
tiring yeah Tessa thank you very much
Dicky arer thank you very much Tom thank
you very much appreciate you coming in
at such short notice tonight on this big
breaking news I'll s next more live
coverage on this extraordinary news that
King Charles has cancer I'll be with my
pck Esther AA and Kevin
[Music]
atin we're here thanks for joining us
you're with talk TV on TV on radio
online and on your smart
speaking criminals to using XL Bully
dogs as weapons to threaten others no
matter how well trained most dog owners
will tell you a dog can turn do you know
I love about talk today we do it all
sunak sella
scon woman can become a man and a man
can become a woman and if you think that
you're certifiably
insane slick rishy seemed intelligent
forensic even a bit of a Statesman the
type of man you trust to look after your
house while you went on
holiday it's concept that actually kids
wouldn't carry knives if they could go
and play Tiddly Winks at the you know
the corner of the street or whatever I
think it's a
nonsense happy THS night we slick it
cing timorous beasty open a pan
and G starm has accused the government
of failing a generation after a record
number of young people were killed last
year using a knife or sharp object we
need to make sure that when we say we're
going to ban them we actually do ban
them there are so many politicians now
who just said my dad was a
boss you're David Cameron no he
wasn't was like brought to you by St KH
the mayor of London very rarely meet
anybody that says you know the thing
about London is it's got great mayor
sadique KH brilliant
guy in the cities there are areas where
there are no vegetables it's
particularly difficult for those people
to do what Mark is saying if he comes up
with this argument again I'll sit on
him stop creating all of these funny
little factions with their funny little
names the new conservatives the ERG the
common sense research group the red wool
red trouser popcorn I mean popcorn what
what is that if you're talking about
multicult ISM it's workingclass white
boys who get put in the Army the poorest
people in society are the ones who are
going to be put on the front line
something is going horribly wrong we can
do a lot better Donald Trump didn't just
win he obliterated this is a guy facing
nearly a 100 criminal charges and yet
all that's done is actually make him
more popular Trump is canny enough to
know that all publicity is good
publicity I don't want a president who's
been impeached if he's able to amb
Boozled you or that's the wake up I did
my 6 months I came back nobody would
touch me I put my head down and
persisted and carried on when I say I am
God I'm not joking did you feel Elvis
was controlling I've been answering your
question you answer mine it's actually
not my job to answer your questions I've
asked you two questions should a mass
stay in power and are they a terror
group you're refusing to answer either
of them that is very telling so TV it's
the only place where you get the truth
you've done a book on poetry poetry and
music for the many I love poetry we can
agree on
that this is talk
[Music]
TV welcome back to unsensed our special
edition on this live breaking news about
King Charles III who has been diagnosed
with cancer I'm joined Now by my pack
talk to contributor cracker Del miror
associate Kevin Maguire and the
political journalist AA Santina well
it's still a bit of a shock isn't it and
we've had a lot of them with the Royals
and health we know we lost Prince
Phillip we lost the queen and then two
weeks ago we suddenly woke up and in the
space of two hours we had Charles in
hospital Kate princess wells in hospital
and now this massive escalation in the
king's Health Kevin I know you're not a
monarchist but for the country this is a
bit of a seismic blow no it isn't look I
I wish him uh a full and speedy recovery
he's more fortunate than the two in five
people who don't get their cancer
treatment to start within the two months
are supposed to on the NHS but you you
you're right because look he's just
become king it was only May eight months
ago he had the
coronation and I admire and respect the
openness in saying he has a form of
cancer but of course the questions will
come which cancer is it what is the
stage how will the treatment proceed
because these are all you all questions
when interesting
doctor Dr Mark seagull theorizing that
because he's not being treated in
hospital as an inpatient he was quite
encouraged by that and he felt that led
more to potentially something like
bladder cancer which is very treatable
apparently in this kind of situation you
know we we don't know but he thought the
fact he wasn't being kept in was a good
sign I I've I've known friends who've
not been treated in hospital and they've
died from cancer and then because of the
the course of treatment cancer 75
whatever it is it's not good AA what you
what do you make of this I mean it's
just blown everything else up the news
it's a huge development as it always is
with the Royals going around the world
what do you think I I mean it's very sad
that a man has got cancer but let's just
remember he is he is but a man he is not
you know any more special just yeah but
you know I think it does make him quite
special he's a celebrity and it's always
very sad when celebrities are onwell and
I completely appreciate that however I
would also say this is a really good
moment in time to talk about statutary
sex pay so King Charles now doesn't have
to work he'll do you know he'll do his
phone call with the prime minister or
whatever but he's not going to his
public engagement 75 years old have to
anyway proba why would you want to be so
chish I'm not being chish what I'm
pointing out is you think a 75y Old King
okay but there'll be has can you talking
about who've woken up and they might be
56 they might need to go to work they be
working at 75 as hard as he does people
who are 50 do you know any 75y old that
works as hard as he does I I what hard
75 get into this today because I feel
bad because a man is unwell and a family
is think I appreciate that but look you
know I think it's a pretty cushy job
that I think many of us could job being
king of I think I would be fine being
King of England I think I could do it as
a side job actually you'd have to
identify as a man which I know you
probably would uh just because you could
right um Esther I I don't share that
view at all I don't think he has an easy
life I think he's had a very tough few
years actually losing both his parents
and then having a a coronation to
replace the most popular longest serving
monar in our history all very very tough
stuff he all the stuff with Harry
disenfranchised from one of his sons I
mean he not had this easy at all um but
whatever this is it's serious I think
from the way this has played out tonight
of course and I think most people are
concerned with actually the
Constitutional implications of this not
just the fact that obviously this is a
man who's in his 70s and he has been
diagnosed with cancer it's obviously
tragic um but there questions will he
have to abdicate you know only about a
year into his reign will happen with
Prince William who has three young
children and you know his his dynamic or
family Dynamic will change radically if
he has to take on more more duties I
think that's probably the the bigger
implications look yes the UK does have
in terms of clinical outcomes some of
the lowest cancer outcomes in the
developed world I mean we're on par with
with Portugal and we spend as much on
our NHS as the whole GDP of Portugal so
you know it is it's not great but at the
end of the day illness doesn't
discriminate I don't think saying that
he has the best care somehow negates the
fact that this is a man with if this was
your grandfather
best you no even if he was your
grandfather you would want him to have
the best I like I'm glad to put out a
statement and they've been more open
than they have in the past the roal
family but but it raises so many
questions they should be answered in
public because he is the ultimate public
figure in the UK which which cancer is
it you think you should be obliged to
say that I do we never knew that about
the other world if he's going to help
other people which he says he wants to
and I think he did talking about his
there might be a time when he does talk
about what type of cancer but the mere
fact he's talking about having cancer
but then you
understand he not he's not Joe public
also this way what if he needs time to
process this I mean we're talking about
we're just talking about this breaking
news quickly
forget guilty of it myself I actually
feel really f for Camila tonight this is
the great love of her life and he is
fighting a battle for his life y uh and
she's got to go out and still be the
queen still do all going to perform all
her functional duties apparently uh he
can't do his but she'll have to do hers
whilst every night going back to the
reality that her husband is is facing
this huge battle you're you're
absolutely right I've been fortunate
I've never I've never been diagnosed
with cancer but again friends family who
are say everything stops everything
stops everything stops when you just
hear uh I'm
sorry and you got William the same with
his wife we don't know what happened
with Kate but it must have been serious
she's off off for for months let's just
pivot slight because we were going to
run tonight uh my interview with the
Prime Minister rishy sunak which I did
over the weekend uh it's actually been
running on our YouTube channel the
appears Morgan sensor YouTube channel
you can see it all there now unedited a
lot of people watching it at the moment
and we're going to run it uh at 11:00
tonight on talk TV it would have uh
aired in this slot if it hadn't been for
the big breaking news obviously uh but
I'll play One Clip that's really blown
up today on social media and get the
packs reaction I can just imagine what
reaction will be from at least two of
them let's take a look I'll bet you ,000
to a refugee charity you don't get
anybody on those planes before the
election will you take that back well I
well I want to get the people on the
planes right of course I want to get the
people on the planes right I want to get
the people on the plan and and you say
you scratching your head Albania is an
example of why it's working we created a
new returns agreement with Albania it
meant that if people came here illegally
we could send them back and you know
what they stopped coming r Lander will
do the same thing for us I do not think
it's going to work for you okay well
we'll have to agree to disagree that's
my Grim prediction but you don't have an
alternative way to solve that problem
then uh no I'm not prime
minister well the truth is I'm not and
if you want the top job these are the
problems that you have to solve I mean
Kevin it was it's blown up as being in a
terrible moment he should never have
done it I think he in his head he was
trying to compute should I take this bed
or not if I don't because it looked like
I don't believe in my policy I didn't
plan it I just thought about it on the
moment I was like I because I I feel
this Rwanda plan is such a weird Hill
for someone as logical and sensible
otherwise as Richie sunak to find
himself dying on which is what what it
looks like it may do to his tenure as
Premier right I think I think you'll win
Albania isn't Rwanda because it's only
albanians go there he's going to send
all sorts of people to Rwanda you should
not have taken that bet and he looked a
naive fool to do so he looked glib Aid I
like your question because I think it
showed the callousness of the Prime
Minister and the politicking that is
going on with this Rwanda policy you
cannot tell me that's a man that cares
about curbing immigration or whatever he
claims to do so I mean that is pure
politic well the reason I the reason I
think it was effective was simply that I
really don't believe this policy is
going to work I do not think before he
has to call the next election he's going
to get any illegal migrant on a plane to
Rwanda it's going to get caught up in
Parliament it's going to get caught up
in in the courts but even if it doesn't
as I said to him you're talking about a
couple of hundred people at vast expense
who may or may not end up in Rwanda well
if they have a legitimate Asylum claim
they don't get sent back to the UK they
stay in Rwanda that doesn't seem right
to me yeah I said none of this seems
right to me yeah and if you take a giant
step back as well you remember that this
is all about curbing the number of
people who are crossing the channel and
if you subscribe to that school of
thought this policy is having no effect
on that whatsoever so you know bigger
problem Esther I said to to him is this
shocking on forecast that we could be
seeing a population of 73 million by
2036 because actually legal immigration
is a far bigger problem for this country
than what is now 30,000 people coming
over on small boats yes I'm concerned
about yet yes it shouldn't be happening
yes I want it stopped but actually when
you've got nearly
800,000 people coming in Legally this
year alone and the projection is our
population dramatically increasing I
want my prime minister focusing on that
well this is the thing because they've
prior prze Randa so much they've taken
the oxygen out of what they really
should be focusing on which is bringing
down legal migration I mean 40% of the
figures that we're seeing in legal
migration or dependence right and many
of them in terms of regions globally are
from this form of chain migration from
Southeast Asia mainly the Tor should be
banging on about that but they're not
they're talking about Rwanda and I do
think that there will be people on the
planes before what you think of the BET
should he should he have taken the bet I
I think he should have taken he should
have taken the bet because he would look
like a wimp otherwise um but I think he
should have also said but don't forget
Pi we're also about legal migration
which is an even bigger priority no
political instincts that's the issue
what he should have said to the bet is
you come back and I'll give you another
interview we're running out of time well
we'll come back again later the week to
this and you can watch the whole richy
sunak interview on our YouTube channel
now and it will air on talk TV at 11:00
well that's it from us on Pi morg sens
tonight a show we didn't expect to do a
show I'm sad to have been doing I Wish
King Charles III and his family all the
very best as he fights cancer and we
just hope that as they say long live the
king and I hope it all goes well to
thank you for watching good
[Music]
night we're here thanks for joining us
you're with talk TV on TV on radio
online on your smart speaker as well
they have made a statement condemning
Hamas we expect to see the crown revisit
Harry's anti-semitic Halloween costume
criminals to using XL Bully dogs as
weapons to threaten others no matter how
well trained most dog owners will tell
you a dog can turn you know what I love
about to today we do it all sunak sella
scun I rather like David Cameron I don't
sort of bear him any your will because
he delivered the referendum that he said
he would deliver the Israelis are very
conciliatory all they want is to be
recognized the timing of this hamus
attack comes because there was the
expectation there was going to be a deal
down to normalizing relations with Saudi
Arabia the Tories love a scrap you can
almost see this coming around the tracks
with sella bravman she's heading up one
side and rishy soon at the other
reshuffles usually very dull this one
had booster Rockets attached to it
certainly the tone has shifted in terms
of what Rashi sunak has done the
question now is what he does next the
police are pro Palestine that is just
not right you swear an o in the police
to act without fear or favor the co
inquiry seems to have turned into a sort
of pantomim there's not really any
substance to it it's hard to know
whether it's a fce or a tragedy talk TV
has spoken exclusively to a member of
the Blade Runners do you have a message
for sadique Khan we're not stopping
until you
stop the amount of time it's taken the
number of illegal migrants currently
sent by us to Rwanda zero built the
amount of money it's cost we're saying
what are we saying it's cost about 140
million £140 million so far so40 million
so far result nil absolutely nil are we
only going to be trusting sources like
meta and Google where is our unbiased
news going to come from Kell in winter
is
cold that is from the Jeremy Corbin book
Kevin O Sullivan is the worst presenter
on talk TV sitting on his fat ass
talking
if you're walking towards me and you're
a vegan you have a great big orange
sticker over here saying watch out
vegan's
about the weirdest plank that we've had
in three years hundreds and hundreds of
mice in a box which he walks into a
branch of McDonald MC Mouse manc mous
man mous he should be easy enough to
catch this guy shouldn't he I mean he's
got a house full of
mice this is a major Summit President
Biden decided this was important after
watching a Tom Cruz film do you think
people underestimate how important music
is for this country it's about 10 times
the size of the fishing industry so the
music industry although it looks fun and
glamorous it's a tough tough industry